hey this is presto Walker this is said
to be one of the most difficult SAT math
problems ever in the figure arc SBT is
1/4 of a circle with center R and radius
6 if the length plus width of rectangle
ABC R is 8 then the perimeter of the
shaded region is which of the following
choices 8 plus 3 PI 10 plus 3 PI 14 plus
3 PI 1 plus 6 PI or 12 plus 6 PI this
was part of a discussion on Quora where
people discussed the most difficult SAT
math problem and this was voted as one
of the most difficult can you figure it
out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution
so how can we solve this problem first
let's write down what we want to solve
for this will be the length of si plus
AC plus CT plus arc SBT now it seems
very difficult so let's break it down
into different steps we'll start out
with the length of the arc we are given
in the problem that the arc SBT is one
quarter of the circle which has a radius
of six so the length of the arc SBT will
be 1/4 of the circumference which is 2
PI R divided by 4 R is equal to 6 so
this simplifies to be 3 pi now how do we
solve for the length of si plus AC plus
CT this seems very difficult because we
don't know the length of si or CT and it
seems like we can solve for AC using the
Pythagorean theorem because we have a
right triangle but that also seems like
it would be pretty complicated so the
trick in this problem is to transform
this length into the lengths of things
that are already presented in the given
information the entire key is seeing
that si can be represented as the length
of SR minus AR similarly CT can be found
as the length of RT minus RC now why
does that help us well the reason is
that we know all of these lengths so
before I get to that let me just
rearrange this equation we're going to
be adding three terms SR AC and RT and
we're going to subtract ar and we're
going to subtract RC and will group them
together so we'll subtract the quantity
AR plus RC from the problem SR is equal
to RT is equal to 6 because each is a
radius of the circle
next what about the length of AC well AC
is a diagonal of this rectangle so it'll
be equal to the other diagonal which is
our B and our B is also a radius of the
circle therefore this is equal to 6
which means AC is also equal to 6
finally we have a R + RC
this is given to us in the problem as
the length plus width of the rectangle
which is equal to 8 so we now know each
of these quantities so we get 6 plus 6
plus 6 minus 8 and this simplifies to be
10 so we put these two parts together to
get that the perimeter of the shaded
region is equal to 10 plus 3 pi and
that's answer choice B did you figure it
out and what method did you use thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions if you like this video you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon you've got a math
topic or a suggestion you can email me
brush at mind your decisions calm and
you can reach me on social media either
at mind your decisions or at presh tell
walker